on a first date with someone we like we
really want of course for the evening to
go well there are many varied bits of
advice in circulation don't do all the
talking
be funny and light ask them about
themselves don't pry select a small
perhaps Italian restaurant leave a
generous tip wear nice shoes wear
understandably nervous we're trying to
do something which is very strange and
tricky seduce another person not so much
in the narrow and potentially sinister
sense of trying to beguile them into
having sex with us but in a larger more
fundamental way of getting them to like
us a date is in essence an audition much
more than we usually admit we're trying
to imagine each other as prospective
long-term partners seduction in its
larger more important sense means
gradually persuading someone that we're
applause abour candidate with whom to be
in a relationship the question then is
what are the things that might properly
show us in this light what do we need to
do to get them on board there are two
central priorities the first is to show
that we have a good relationship to
ourselves this doesn't involve saying
how wonderful we are or what exciting
lives we lead our culture hints that it
might be seductive to say things like I
love Paris's museums or I'm excellent at
swimming in moonlit lakes but such
statements don't really convey that we
will be pleasant or even bearable to
live with day to day on the contrary
what makes us attractive as a potential
partner is the degree to which we can
recognize our own failings it's not that
we should exhibit our flaws getting
furious with a waiter starting to weep
about an old friend who let us down or
going on throughout the first course
about an insult at work that happened
years ago this is weakness unbound given
total victory what is really sweet and
charming that is powerfully reassuring
is weakness handled strongly for example
it can be hugely seductive to drop in
with an air of confidence and wit you
know coming here made me a bit nervous
that's a sign both of insight and
strength we're not simply being nervous
gulping down a cocktail or frantically
insisting that the decor is wonderful
we're vulnerable but have an overview on
our anxieties and the capacity to handle
them lightly it can be equally seductive
to mention in passing as you can imagine
after that I had a little temper tantrum
with myself but in a profoundly calm and
smiling tone that indicates both an
accurate ability to dislike oneself at
points and a mature ability to digest
and learn from ones less impressive
moments at the heart of seductive self
revelation is the idea I'm a touch crazy
of course but very much sane enough to
tell you about it in a modest
unhistorical way we're indicating that
we have the best possible relationship
with our own shadow sides the second
hugely seductive move is to signal that
we view the other person with a mixture
of tenderness and realism it's often
imagined that it'll be seductive to
convey an air of adoration to hint that
the other strikes us as exceptionally
attractive or accomplished but
surprisingly it's deeply worrying to be
obviously adored because everyone from
the inside knows very well that they
don't deserve intense acclaim are often
disappointing and sometimes quite simply
pitiful so seduction involves suggesting
both that one likes the other person a
lot and yet can see their frailties
clearly enough that one can cope with
them and forgive them with gentle
indulgence one might towards the end of
the evening drop in a small warm tease
that alludes to our understanding of
some less than perfect side of them I
suppose you stayed on to the duvet
feeling a bit sorry for yourself after
that we might ask with a benign smile
such a gesture implies that we like
another person not under a mistaken
notion that they are flawless but with a
full-on frightened appreciation of their
frailties that ends up being powerfully
seductive because it is first and
foremost reassuring it suggests the
ideal way that we would like someone to
us within the testing conditions of a
real relationship
we crave not admiration but to be
properly known and yet still liked and
forgiven many things are in the moment
exciting but self-knowledge and
perceptive generosity are the most
properly seductive things in the world
because they are what make life with
another person bearable they are would
indicate that we have what it would take
to embark on the long exciting beautiful
and intermittently extremely painful
journey beyond a first date we love
bringing you these films if you want to
help us to keep bringing you thoughtful
content please consider supporting us by
visiting our shop at the link on your
screen now
you